welcome ladies and gentlemen i'm derek
briggs the director of the
Peabody Museum of Natural History and
it's my honor and privilege to introduce
the first of this year's series of hairy
lectures which as you know are on
Jefferson and Darwin science and
religion in troubled times the
lectureship was established in 1905 by a
gift from Dwight Harrington Terry of
Bridgeport Connecticut it the fund
matured sufficiently in 1923 to start
the series of lectures and as you know
it's among Yale's most distinguished
lecture ships and has yielded a series
of important books continues to which
are published by Yale University Press
under the editorship of Jean Thompson
black the deed of gift states
amongst other things that it is desired
that a series of lectures be given by
men eminent in their respective
departments on ethics the history of
civilization and religion biblical
research all Sciences and branches of
knowledge which have an important
bearing on the subject all the great
laws of nature especially of evolution
and of course the lectureship has
invited many preeminent scholars
tonight's speaker adds luster to a list
that includes Joseph Needham Carl Jung
Gigi Simpson Margaret Mead Michael
Polanyi Steve Gould John Polkinghorne
Francis Ayala to mention just a few and
ironically the first Terry lectures in
1923 were given by another Thompson Sir
John Arthur Thompson entitled simply
concerning evolution and like Keith this
afternoon Arthur Thompson was also from
Britain a Scottish naturalist who was
concerned with reconciling science and
religion and whose scientific speciality
was soft
corrals so in some sense our speaker
requires no introduction
Keith as I said is an Englishman he was
educated at the University of Birmingham
and then at Harvard and spent a
considerable part of his career here at
Yale where he was professor of biology
director of the Peabody Museum one of my
predecessors and Dean of the Graduate
School of Arts and Sciences subsequently
he became president and CEO of the
Academy of Natural Sciences in
Philadelphia was a distinguished
scientist in residence at the New School
for Social Research and then director of
the Oxford University Museum until 2003
and if one could in any sense describe
Keith is retired
he is currently professor emeritus of
Natural History at the University of
Oxford and executive officer of the
American Philosophical Society his
interests are very diverse but we're
going to focus of course in these
lectures on his interest in Thomas
Jefferson an 18th century science and of
course Charles Darwin and it would take
me probably another two or three minutes
to read all the titles of Keith's books
so let's give me I'll give you just a
few before Darwin reconciling God and
nature Yale 2005 the legacy of the
mastodon the Golden Age of fossils in
America also Yale 2008 a passion for
nature Thomas Jefferson and Natural
History and most recently the Yale book
on the young Charles Darwin and of
course a new book
Jefferson's shadow the story of his
science will be published later this
year by Yale University Press so without
further ado professor Keith Thompson
thanks to her
well thank you very much I have to say
it's a great honor to be invited to give
these lectures which I knew so well from
when I was here on the faculty and
something of a daunting challenge I like
particularly to thank the Terry
committee for having the courage or the
full hardiness to invite me to give
these lectures
I'd like to single out for special
mention Jean Thompson black who is
another Thompson burr despised I know no
relative except that all the brilliant
Thompson's are related and I also want
to mention at a risk of embarrassing her
my wife Linda Thompson who has seen me
through some very tricky times in the
last 12 months so that's that's
especially important to mention well the
wording of the Terry lectures offers
rather a daunting challenge as I have
said because what Derrick missed out is
that it aims towards building on the
truths of science and philosophy into a
structure of broadened and purified
religion that is a daunting challenge
you can't read these words without
extend recognizing the extent to which
science and religion have diverged in
the last two centuries to the point of
being almost unrecognizable to each
other and today it seems almost as
though they are more antithetical to
each other than they ever have been
before and rarely rarely do they
interact positively so in what follows
are what I want to do is avoid the usual
siren calls of the anti religious and
the anti science propaganda which is so
prevalent in the press at the moment and
work from some the very simple
narratives about real people in counting
problems in religion and science and as
a scientists are not qualified to
pronounce on theology as a historian of
science however I can trace some events
characters debates of the past and see
how they impinge on our lives which I
think are no less troubled than say
Jefferson's time
or Darwin's time and excuse me I will
try to show that the there is just as
pressing a need in this century as there
was in the 18th century for the two
sides to try and find some common ground
and the two people I'm going to talk
about first Jefferson and Darwin two men
whose intellect work and lives I mostly
admire but not as will become a parent
always someone who will also appear at
intervals just to irritate you will be
Benjamin Disraeli now a key problem for
any age and particularly for us is
dealing with change change is not always
comfortable and I think it's at the root
of the present difficulties with respect
to a religion and science and it's a
curious and frustrating fact that
science which seems to be aimed to
producing hard truths and enviable laws
it's constantly changing its mind and
frustrating us I can give you no better
example than the fact that the universe
now seems to consist of something called
dark matter and dark energy which nobody
knew anything about ten years ago twenty
years ago it was constant and then it
was expanding to uniform velocity and
now it's accelerating it's very hard to
know what to make a wall of this said
that 2009 Terry lectures looked at the
question of why there continued to be a
debate between religion and science and
I want to look at it from a slightly
different point of view the main point I
want to dwell in on is that the so
called conflict between religion and
science is actually part of a much
broader phenomenon wherever there is
change in our knowledge and excuse me
there isn't always outright conflict but
there always some difficulty when we
come up against something new it could
be as simple as hearing a piece of very
modern music for the first time I'm
wondering about it or seeing it frankly
modern painting it doesn't fit what we
know these little free sounds of
conflict difference what build up now
epidemiologists and fizz and and
philosophers tell us that what we know
is a mixture of two things things we
know personally and things that we take
on authority from others and that's part
of the problem because what we take on
Authority or what authority and
convention has to offer almost never
changes as fast as new knowledge and new
information does we are all if you sum
up what we know a mixture of what I call
ancient and modern everything from the
classics and the Bible to what we read
in the newspaper yesterday I call it
ancient and modern because that was the
name of the popular hymn book when I was
a boy hymns ancient and modern and they
kept on changing it having new very
unpleasant hymns and so it become a
symbol of that popping in of the new
just where it wasn't needed now
sometimes when a new bit of information
pops up it's accepted almost immediately
the best example I know is thomas henry
huxley
when he read Darwin's theory of
evolution for this time first time he
said no doubt slapping his forehead how
extremely stupid of me not to have
thought of that now still the case that
the majority of people around the world
reading Darwin's theory for the first
time say oh my dead body so there is
that now sometime our response to new
information is to go through contorted
efforts to what it will save the
phenomenon have-your-cake-
and-eat-it-too and the classic example
of that is ptolemies a series of crystal
spheres which explain the movement of
the planets except that didn't explain
why Mars and Jupiter sometimes went
backwards and so we had to save the
phenomenon by inventing epicycles on the
cycles and so on
that's savings phenomenon and you almost
always lose some
in that and perhaps the communist
response to new knowledge is to do
nothing just wait and see what happens
it may be things will become clearer
later in the very first of the terrier
lectures my predecessor as professor as
well as your dogs with Thompson said in
his book I made a very interesting
remark he said there is always a tax on
new knowledge it isn't free you have to
pay for new knowledge now we often think
of science and religion as two great
philosophical and institutional bear
must bashing into each other
and I want to emphasize that one of the
key to understanding all this is not
there but is in the lives of individuals
encountering the new for the first time
there is a certainly an exciting moment
when Galileo stands before the tribunal
but what an exciting moment when the
young Galileo reads Copernicus or Kepler
for the first time and says oh my god
what am I going to do or there's a very
nice piece in John Bonneville's novel
dr. Kemper nachus Copernicus had gone to
Krakow to study with a man called
professor Adelbert the juice key who was
the classic expert on ptolemy had the
textbook on ptolemy and of course he had
been toying with all sorts of
sun-centered universe is and didn't know
where he was he was a very young man
Nicholas had read everything the
professor had written on tomate
Ptolemaic theory but out of there was
weary hours there had been distilled one
day precious a precious drop a pearly
doubt he could no remember no longer
remember where or when he had found the
floor along what star each objectory on
which rung of those steadily ascending
ladders of tabular calculation but once
detected it brought the entire edifice
of a life's work crashing down with slow
dreamlike in ever
ability professor birch juice key knew
that Ptolemy was gravely wrong so here
is the crux of the problem great man and
ordinary people coming together in this
same problem of dealing with something
new that runs into convention or
authority in the first example I'll talk
about Thomas Jefferson dealing with
geology he was extremely interested in
science but he when he got to geology he
got two questions he couldn't answer and
if there was one thing that Jefferson
hated it was a question that he couldn't
answer Jefferson above all had to be
right in the second case
Darwin having kin discovered what he
actually called a new system of the
world with his theory of natural
selection found it ran headlong into
conventional religion and instead of
charging ahead as I will show you he
blinked now f scott Fitzgerald famously
wrote in the crack-up the test of a
first-class intelligent is the ability
to hold two opposed ideas in the mind at
the same time and still remain retain
the ability to function but in fact you
can all do that and so could Thomas
Jefferson so before we get to Jeff's I
need to digress just a little bit to set
the stage I began my academic career as
a biologist and I've become more of a
historian and I don't know if you can
stop being a biologist or a scientist
but here I am I've been fascinated by
Jefferson's reaction to an interest in
science and Darwin's and by the fact
that they lived that between them is the
cusp of enormous change in science and
secular society and everything it's 50
years between Jefferson writing notes on
the state of Virginia and Charles Darwin
returning from the voyage of the Beagle
just 50 years and yet the changes
between those two dates are absolutely
astronomical
now one things I like most about science
is its occassionally capacity really to
amaze you and I never ever since I was a
young man got over the fact of
Democritus and leucippus producing a
theory and automata at atomic theory of
the universe encapsulated in two
questions familiar to you from
Democritus nothing exists except atoms
and empty space everything else is
opinion and everything existing in the
universe is a fruit of chance and
necessity by which he meant chance and
law which is not bad for the 4th or 5th
century BC now of course you could be
accused of being triumphalist about that
and surely there were millions of people
who had equally crazy ideas that
actually were crazy but you've got to
give them some credit and it was very
dangerous obviously because What did he
say about free will as Laplace put it if
you could comprehend all the forces
acting on those atoms and you knew their
velocity then you knew where they had
been and you would know where they are
going in that case where is free will
now the strict after atomist view left
no room for outside of the material
world and the most obvious most popular
obvious alternative is the view that the
world has been created by and is even
daily controlled by supernatural powers
the gods or God and the evidence for
this has always been taken to be the
extraordinary complexity and diversity
of the natural world in which very to
which various AI writers have added its
beauty its marriage of form and function
is utility for human life and so on in
Jefferson and Darwin's time this was
called natural theology and here is how
Jefferson described it in his own belief
which is important for us to know I hold
without appeals of Revelation that is
I'm not being told by anybody else that
when we take a view of the universe in
its parts general or particular it is
impossible for the human
not to perceive and feel a conviction of
design consummate skill and infinite
power in every atoms of its composition
I say it is impossible for the human
mind not to believe that there is in all
this design cause and effect up to an
ultimate cause a fabricator of all
things from matter to motion and so on
it's a bit of a long-winded long letter
to John Adams actually and Newton in his
Principia wrote it a little bit more
simply this most elegant system of the
Sun planets and comets could not have
arisen without the design and dominion
of an intelligent and powerful being the
third theme that I want to mention that
science and religion is part of a
particular problem that is useful to
look at the individuals is that is very
difficult in this subject to say
anything new this whole idea about
design of course persists today in an
elaborate and very dominant form called
intelligent design theory and William
Paley in 1800 gave the great example of
if some savage was walking along the
field and he picked up a watch he
wouldn't know what it was for
necessarily but he have to conclude that
it was built by somebody and it had a
purpose it had a designer and if that
watch had a purpose and a designer then
what about the fat savage himself who
picked it up and so on the not a new
idea not a new idea with Cicero who
wrote in Dane a torrid night day Orem
suppose a traveller to carry into
Sevilla or Britain the orrery recently
constructed by our friend Posidonia
switch at each revolution reproduces the
same motions of the Sun the moon and the
five planets that take place in the
heavens every 24 hours would any single
native doubt this re was the work of
that's in the first century BC and I
want you to notice that when he wanted
to find a savage who was completely
committed he picked out Britain now
another thing that anti-evolutionists
always coming up with is if you gave a
monkey a typewriter would he ever
produce the phrase from Shakespeare and
I cannot imagine anywhere won't think
that if a countless numbers of copies of
the one and twenty letters of the
alphabet made of gold or what you will
were thrown together in some receptacle
and then shaken out onto the ground it
would be possible they should produce
the handles of any Asst I doubt whether
they could possibly succeed in producing
a single verse it's um it's a bit like
Edna st. Vincent Millay
it's not the same damn thing over and
over
it's sorry it's not one damn thing after
another it's the same thing over and
over here we go all the way from Cicero
to intelligent design theory now define
what I mean by religion or science at
this moment and I notice a lot of books
on the subject very carefully don't do
that but I think it's necessary to get
out the old first edition of the Oxford
English Dictionary and which tells us
that relief religion is belief that
there is a God outside of our material
world who controls our lives and destiny
fundamental metal mental or moral
attitudes results from this belief as
well as standards for spiritual and
practical life elements of particular
rites and observances and many symbols
and science is a natural a field of
inquiry or applied to organize knowledge
leading to the discovery of general laws
and restricted to those branches of
study that relate to the phenomena of
the natural of material universe and
their laws science doesn't deal with
obvious where observations can't be made
directly measurements taken or
experiments for
formed David Hume in his inquiry
concerning human understanding expressed
things really quite well if we take in
our hand any volume of divinity or
school metaphysics for instance let us
ask does it contain any abstract this
reasoning concerning quantity or number
no does it contain any experimental
reasoning concerning matter of fact and
existence no then commit it to the
flames for it contains nothing but
sophistry and illusion now new york
times i guess towards the end of last
year had a very interesting letter from
the chief communications officer of the
so called Creation Museum in Kentucky
which is getting a lot of press and a
lot of visitors and it is run by the
telogen Design Institute people in
Seattle and this is his scientific
philosophy accepting the Bible as God's
literal truth doesn't mean that we
discount science it does mean that we
interpret scientific evidence from a
biblical viewpoint evidence isn't
labeled with dates and facts we arrive
at conclusions about the unobservable of
past based on our pre-existing beliefs
now if that doesn't count as sophistry
and illusion I I don't know what does so
I have to declare my Philistine ism if
you like debates about whether there is
objective knowledge or not they're all
very well but in order to get anything
done the scientist has to be assumed
that there is argument without the dates
and facts is mere opinion and in the
same pragmatic spirit I want to state
that arguments about whether there is a
God or not in one sense are quite
irrelevant if enough people believe
there is a God and act on their beliefs
then that is a fact that has to be
accommodated by more than calling them
boneheaded and stupid a reference you
will detect to my Oxford call
the professor Richard Dawkins so now
let's finally get to poor old Thomas
Jefferson who's been waiting in the
wings because this science and religion
thing
it focuses so much on Darwin but it was
a big issue long before then as you
could see going back to Cicero in his
commonplace book for 1810 I mean entry
for 1810 Benjamin Rush had a very
interesting observation it would seem
that natural knowledge instead of
leading men to God geology and botany of
spoiled revelation so it's interesting
that he become geology I I can talk
about the botany bit later but I won't
here wants to talk about geology so so
Jefferson he was the most complex of men
obviously deeper thinker than any
president except possibly Madison and
intellectual hero but not to the
military one of the war independence and
by terms charming passionate ruthless
admirable and despicable and it's
remarkable that someone will Revere so
much for his declaration event of
Independence should it be so vilified as
I will come to in a moment in the
election of 1800 now he's relevant to us
because he was the most rational man so
it's interesting to look at Jefferson
encountering the science religion
problem the new old new conventional new
Authority and so on because sighs
science was central to Jefferson's life
views of his enormous library of over
six thousand volumes one-third were
books on science there was no other
category that has as many entries even
than the law now Jefferson was a deist
I've read his his natural theological
views and he didn't believe in anything
to do with Christianity as you know he
produced a really fascinating document
that really ought to be read more which
is the New Testament with the miracles
taken out
and it's it's just if it may imitate you
but it's it just gives you such a
completely different viewpoint of the
New Testament of the gospel the four
Gospels it's it's absolutely fabulous
and of course as a man of reasons he
totally rejected miracles now a lot of
Jefferson's scientific views were
directed against count Buffon in Paris
as you well know and this isn't
surprising because a lot of science and
a lot of the other parts of the
intellectual world I discover people who
spent a lot of their time recruiting
against other people and other ideas
while they're thinking about their own
people and their own ideas being against
is just terribly important a bit sad but
it's just it's very important and
Jefferson may have made his scientific
career in his don't demolition of
bluefangs ideas about natural history
which he wrote up in the notes in the
state of Virginia now Jefferson really
knew his geology he lived in the Blue
Ridge Mountains he rode walked in the
Blue Ridge Mountains
he knew the coastal plain he knew the
Piedmont which is the land below the
mountains and he knew the mountains
themselves and he knew that the rocks
making up the mountains of the Blue
Ridge and other mountains were folded in
complicated ways nothing simple about
the structure of the Blue Ridge
Mountains but funnily enough if you went
immediately west beyond the Shenandoah
and the last Ridge of the Blue Ridge
into the great western plains that go
all the way to what was then called the
great stony mountains there all the beds
of the rocks were completely horizontal
it was a very telling observation which
he was one of the first to really write
about seriously so Jefferson was sure
almost sure that the Blue Ridge around
mountains and those folded rocks and
whatnot were the way God had made the
world but he wasn't completely sure
because it was such a mess if you look
at the mountains from the distance they
seemed majestic
Reagle and snow they're just beautiful
if you look at them close up you get
what Thomas Burnett said after
travelling in the Swiss Alps in 1681 we
must be impartial where the truth
requires it and describe the earth as it
really is it is a broken and confused
heap of bodies placed in no order to one
another nor with any correspondence E or
regularity of parts a will lying in its
own rubbish so this is the question
this was the dilemma for everybody in
the 17th 16th and 18th centuries sure
where did mountains come from were they
in this confused fashion part of God's
original design or what they produced
later by some catastrophic change for
which there was absolutely no biblical
Authority now of course they might all
been caused by all this chaos by the
great flood of Noah and I'll come to
that in a moment or it could have been a
comet after 1701 and Edmund Halley
there was a flurry of books about comet
theories comets hitting the earth and
making mountains and so on in 1668
Nicholas steno had a really kind of a
nice idea the mountains weren't raised
up the land around them kept collapsing
into the earth leaving the mountains
standing there but it was actually quite
good and he published this in Florence
about 20 years after Galileo and it was
at the back of the book has a stamp of
approval of the Inquisition so we can
trace Jefferson's geological thinking's
both from the state of Virginia and the
notes on the state of Virginia and his
correspondence with the Secretary of the
Continental Congress man that your
typical eighteenth-century polymath he
was secretary to Congress or authority
on American Indians first American
Translate of the Bible and his name of
course was Charles Thompson now it was
clear that Jefferson knew all the
available theories Buffa's theory was to
be ill and others too was the earth had
from a glowing molten blob probably part
of the Sun and so he did experiments by
heating cannonballs too as to white heat
and seeing how long they took to cool
down and he worked out the earth must be
75,000 years old which was you know a
pretty good interesting experiment for
this at the 1700s again not much in
about in there about that in the Bible
now if you had a very interesting idea
the earth is an oblate spheroid not a
sphere and they did know that then and
his idea was that if you solidify a
molten mass as it spins round it
automatically forms the shape of a knob
Lord spirit oblate spheroids rather than
a sphere Jefferson had exactly the
opposite idea first of all he said an
oblate spheroid is exactly the shape you
need if the rotation is going to be
fixed on its axis and not wobble that's
the ideal thing and of course if that's
the ideal shape God would have made it
that way a an argument this is a little
difficult to to counter so in those on
the Virginia if you took on this
question of where mountains came from
and he had four different ideas first of
all he rejected the pot oh sorry
actually go back again one of the ways
that people have focused on this
question of mountains had to do with
fossils and Jefferson was fascinated by
what we call fossils and so that's where
he focused his ideas about the origin of
mountains because if you go up a
mountain whether it's the Blue Ridge or
the Andes you can go way up and find
fossils dead of fossils so looking as
though they were once on the seashore so
giving tremendous credence to the idea
that the mountains were actually raised
up from the seabed so Jefferson had
collected fossils in the
fossil shells in the in the Blue Ridge
and so he listed the possibilities first
they could have been deposited there by
the flood that was the classic idea but
he worked out that a worldwide flood was
quite impossible in order to cover the
Blue Ridge let alone the Andes that
simply isn't that much water vapor in
the atmosphere it was a good argument
perhaps the mountains had been thrust up
by some in that unimaginable force but
the key word is unimaginable how now
maybe the mighty seas had receded like
destino said but where did they go to
and there was a fourth possibility now I
mentioned earlier saving the phenomenon
and for a while
Jefferson toyed with saving the
phenomenon Voltaire and others had been
pushing the idea for a long time that
fossils were not the remnants of real
once-living animals but it actually
grown in the rocks that rocks grow like
like a tree grows and somehow they
produce these shapes mimicking real
shelves and when Jefferson was in in
Paris he went on a trip to Italy and the
South of France and tried to chase down
a rumor that someone had actually got a
lot of evidence that this has actually
happened a man called DISA sir and I
couldn't do it but it was very very
tempting because if the rocks grew their
own fossils then they didn't have to
have been thrust up and out of the out
of the ocean floor however while I hope
withhold my assent from this hypothesis
I must deny it to every other I have
ever seen one would rather therefore
have no opinion than a false one and
then unable to choose between the altar
among the alternatives he wrote at the
end of this passage in notes on the
state of Virginia there is a wonder
somewhere they seemed so harmless to
have written there is a wonder somewhere
and of course it was quite blasphemous
there was no wonder at all if God had
made it that way now
Jefferson was extremely conservative
there and wanting to force his religious
views conventional religious view onto
the science and he was even more
conservative when it came to the fossils
because he never once used the word
fossil pick up any book on Jefferson you
learn about his love of fossils the
fossil Mastodon the fossil megalonyx and
whatnot never used the word because he
did not believe that any of those
species became extinct he did not
believe that extinction was possible he
wrote again to Charles Thompson on this
very subject he thought it was crazy to
imagine that God would have made species
and then let them go extinct and start
again as he the Creator intended the
earth for the habitation of animals and
vegetables is it reasonable to assume he
made two jobs of his creation he loved
to be sarcastic he's really sarcastic
about Buffon essential it's really
wonderful that he first made a chaotic
lump and set it into rotatory motion
then waiting the millions of ages
necessary to form itself but when it had
done that he stepped in a second time to
create the animals and plants which were
to inhabit it as the hand of the
creator's to be called in it might as
well be called in at one stage or
another we might as well suppose he
created the earth at once nearly in the
state in the state in which we see it
fit for the preservation of the beings
he placed on it now there's a little key
phrase in there which you missed because
everybody does
he created the worth world at once
nearly in the state in which we see it
all of it at once
some of it at once some of it later
where is this going to fit in with its
religious views
in notes on the state of Virginia he
talks about he loves sublime landscapes
he this was a passion of his and he
talks about the place where the Potomac
and the Shenandoah River break through
the Blue Ridge Mountains you think of
the Blue Ridge Mountains going your way
they go this way and they're folded on
there these magnificent valleys like the
Shenandoah Valley which go hundreds of
miles beautiful bottom land for farming
and so on and the rivers in them go
along the valleys but they have to get
out to the sea and he couldn't work out
why until he went to look at the place
where they actually broke through and
it's a very nice piece of writing on
your right comes up the Shenandoah
having ranged along the front of the
mountains a hundred miles to seek event
on your left approaches the Potomac in
quest of a passage also in the moment of
their junction they rush together
against the mountain rend it asunder and
passed off to the sea the first glance
of the scene hurries our senses into
this opinion that this earth has been
created in time now the mountains were
formed first that the rivers began to
flow afterwards that in this place
particularly they've been dammed up by
the Blue Ridge of mountains and have
formed an ocean which filled the whole
valley that continuing to the rise they
have a length of broken over at this
spot and have torn the mountain dime
from his summit to its base most
powerful agent in nature and the key
phrase in this is the opinion that the
earth had been created in time over time
not instantly so in the same book he's
writing several different things about
what it is that happened at creation was
it a creation or has the earth changed
enormously over time now the phrase
created in time was not noticed until
the election of 1800 when it was lept
upon that election coincided with two
things the very broad Christian revival
movement
and of course the unfortunate invention
of political parties and I'm gonna have
to skip over this next bit I'm sorry one
of the people who hated Jefferson most
was interesting enough a man called
Clement see more and visit from st. Nick
or twas the night before Christmas
Jefferson's geology Oh
whenever modern philosophers talk about
mountains something impious is likely to
be at hand
Jefferson's geology seems to possess
every qualification which the heart of a
modern philosopher could desire it is
bold plausible and count contrary to
Scripture
notes on the state of Virginia tends to
the subversion of religion to examine
whether from the brilliance of invention
acuteness of investigation or the cogent
argument we're entitled to call this any
more than modern French philosophy for
words
no three words created in time that's
it's kind of interesting
other people critical notes on the state
of Virginia because of in his interest
in mastodons and his political right
enemy the journalist Luther Mountain
Martin described notes as being nothing
more than an exercise in weighing mice
and measuring the genitalia of Indians
and if you like I can get into that
later
another journalist Thomas Jefferson to
make the best of him was nothing but a
mean-spirited low-lived fellow a son of
a half-breed Indian [ __ ] sired by a
Virginian mulatto father and raised
wholly on hoecake bacon and hominy with
an occasional woops sorry
change of fricassee bullfrog for which
abominable reptiles he acquired a taste
during his residence among the French in
Paris now this is good electioneering
stop we the election going on at the
moment but it's nothing here's somebody
else talking about Jefferson and his
party for what end should we be
connected with men of whom this is the
character and conduct is it that we may
see our wives and daughters the victims
of legal prostitution soberly dishonored
speciously polluted the outcasts of
delicacy and virtue 1798 the duty of
Americans at the present crisis Timothy
Dwight president of Yale College while
all this had been going on geologists
and biblical scholars have formed an
unholy allowing alliance showing that
the Bible the first chapters of Genesis
could not possibly be true the
philologists in Germany have worked out
that a lot depending on how you
translated the words that in the King
James Version are created and made and
the geologists of course had worked out
that the earth was extremely old now we
know Jefferson knew something about this
because he wrote to Adams and that
wonderful correspondence they had in
their later years about the ten
commandments the whole history of these
books is so defective and doubtful that
it seems vain to attempt minut inquiry
into it and such tricks have been played
with their text and with the texts of
other books related to them what we have
the right from that cause to entertain
much about the doubt which part
are genuine by 1830 Benjamin silhouette
silliman here at the college was
preaching that the first day of curation
and teaching in his geology classes that
the first day of creation was an
unknowable long period and that the days
of creation were not literal days but
long periods but then nothing new
there's the Centaurus Dean had said that
in his little literal interpretation of
Genesis now to wind up Charles Miller
who wrote a very influential book called
Jefferson nature states that Jefferson
had a disrespect for geology he was
uninformed impatient and also had an
ultimately confusing discussion I think
that's kind of hard that's probably a
bit impatient in itself we can't always
expect our heroes or our villains to be
so clear-headed as we are in the case of
geology Jefferson had this incredible
conflict there was the authority which
he had created from himself because he'd
done it rationally of a religious view
of how the earth ought to be produced
and there was this nagging geological
information which basically wasn't very
good it was not yet as convincing as it
would be say in 1831 when Darwin went
off on the Beagle with Charles Lyell's
geology in his hand a lot happened in
that 5 in that 50 years in 1805 he wrote
to Duvall me the French immigrant
anthropologist and geographer who came
full of hope and then was driven out by
the Alien and Sedition Acts he said he
no longer indulged in geological
inquiries the skin-deep crashes
scratches which we can make or find on
the surface of the earth do not repay
time with a certain and useful
deductions as our pursuit in other
branch
he rejected what geology had to say to
him or rather he said it didn't have
anything to say that was useful to his
religious worldview another letter I've
written three years before he died so
1823 shows that in fact he kept up with
all the current geological theories
after all and I'll just refer to the man
we don't have time to go what they are
the dreams about the modes of creation
inquiries about whether our globe has
been formed by the agency of fire or
water how many million years it has cost
Vulcan or Neptune puts you to produce
what the Fiat of the Creator would
affect by a single act of will is to
idols to be worth a single hour of man's
life but he knew the theories this
reference to Vulcan and Neptune shows
that he'd been keeping up with it right
up to his old age he was then 80 now
that seems kind of damning what he said
not worth a single hour of any man's
life but this was a letter to a man
called John Emmett in which he is
recommending the curriculum for the new
University of Virginia and what is the
last item on the last page of the
curriculum of the University of Virginia
geology so to sum up I think that this
business of a conflict science and
religion is part of a general problem
whenever things something new crops up
it's not unique to science and religion
although obviously it's it's very
important to science in religion and I'm
going to try and develop that in further
lectures but when you come to look at
the individual each person has to
accommodate change new information in
their own way and it's in the nature of
change that change and convention and
authority will always change at
different speeds so they'll always be
difficulties Jefferson chose to ignore
science in my next talk I'll discuss
Charles Darwin Charles Darwin had
the opposite problem he had all the
science he needed and he was very sure
of it
but he couldn't accommodate what he
really thought about religion so looking
at his Jefferson's all-too-human
approach to geology which is after all a
very dull subject I'm just saying that
for culture Ricans benefit if scott
Fitzgerald would write about holding two
opposed ideas at the same time and
retaining the ability function then I
just say Jefferson has a really superior
mind and just as confused as the rest of
us thank you